what is it with some leaders
that constantly feel they can change
victims
meaning you've worked with somebody who
is extremely you know what i'm talking
about
you probably thought about five names
you have somebody in your company
somebody in your organization
who you know you see greatness in this
person this person could be a hero
this person could go out there and do
incredible things but behind closed
doors it's your fault it's your fault
it's a company's fault it's the
industry's fault my wife's fault it's my
friend's fault
everybody's fault except theirs and they
may be the most talented person in your
company
did you ever have to give up trying to
change victims and if yes what was your
formula
yes and not only do we have to try to
give up changing victims
we have to give it up every day
what i give somebody who's playing first
of all it's
it's spoken in our culture we define
victim mentality it's not a mystery
so people now recognize it in themselves
they know that that's not going to be
valued here
and so that took care of 80 percent of
the problem right there because you had
the the people who used that tactic
the victim flop i call it flopping you
know like a premier league soccer player
they flop and act like they're injured
and then they jump up and score a goal
there's you know they're fine there's
nothing wrong so that no longer
uh works in my company and then what i
tend to do is have to remind myself this
happened a couple days ago just
hey you know the person's going to play
a victim there's nothing we can do it
it's not our job to change them
what i want to do though is give them an
opportunity to play the heroes
i want to sit down and say let me
explain to you your very
clear opportunity to make a lot more
money uh
to to have all these things come your
way to have a great career
here's your opportunity if you can do
these things
and i have actually seen transformation
with some
where they look at that and they say
well all i needed to know were the rules
of the game and you just taught me the
rules of the game
so now i'm going to play the game and
gain some confidence that i can actually
win at this game
and so i've seen that happen but it is
not it's just not our responsibility to
do that
and i would i would actually say a lot
of us we
just like you discovered in your dating
relationships patrick i didn't get
married till i was 42 years old
i had some pretty rocky relationships in
there a couple of them were because
somebody played the victim and it made
me feel really
good about myself to go in and rescue
them
but there's a psychologist named kaufman
who has something called coffins
triangle he says when you rescue
somebody you begin to resent them
and build up tension because they're
sacking
they're sapping all of your energy and
they won't take responsibility for their
lives
so that thing where we it makes us feel
good actually comes back and bites us at
the end
uh what we want are a team of
high-performing
heroic individuals and guides who will
uh who will transform the lives of our
customers by solving their problems
uh everything else we need to go see a
counselor and say why am i trying to
rescue people
you know can i tell you a weird story
patrick please actually i actually
uh i went and saw a counselor once and
it was at the
request of a friend who has a
therapeutic retreat center he said you
should spend some time figuring this
stuff out
and i only went in dealing with my
business stuff i'd already gone and
dealt with all my relational stuff
codependency all that stuff it's an
important journey
and she said tell me something you want
to work on
and i said okay well i've got a couple
staff members who i really love
they're like little brothers to me and i
really want to pay them a lot of money
and i
dream about their future and all this
kind of stuff i'm tempted to think maybe
i want to overpay them sometimes or be a
rescue or something like that
and i can't figure out why and she said
okay
she said how old is the one of these
guys she named him i said he's about 26
years old
she said tell me where you were when you
were 26
and i said when i was 26 i was the
president of a small publishing company
i had transformed this company we became
the fastest growing publishing company
in our segment
and i was so proud of the work i've done
she said don how did your boss feel
about that i said he didn't feel any way
about it he was an absentee owner
he wasn't paying attention in fact he
hired a consultant to figure out why we
were growing the consultant had to tell
him it's because of this kid this guy
dom
and she said so let me get this straight
when you were 26 your boss did
not affirm you or compensate you fairly
and i said yes and she goes
isn't it obvious what you're doing and i
said no it's not i'm she said
don you're trying to compensate your 20s
yourself yeah
wow she had me do this patrick this was
really trippy it was weird
she said okay i'm going to put him in
this chair she goes i want you now to go
sit in his chair
and be him and look back at yourself and
say here's what i actually need
and i went and i did it and i looked at
myself in that empty chair and i said oh
my gosh it's so clear
i need a clear job description i need
clear objectives and i need to be
compensated based on performance
it was just a fascinating revelation you
know so the reality is we're bringing
all sorts of our garbage and our baggage
into our work every day and thank
goodness i have a gracious staff who
forgives me of that and knows i'm
willing to work on it
but we've got to constantly be working
on those temptations to
to rescue people you know you don't want
to be doing that stuff
i interviewed um he actually reminds me
of you in our short time together
patrick i interviewed pete carroll who's
the head of the seattle seahawks i think
they're going to win a super bowl this
year
uh they're amazing i interviewed him a
few years ago
and i said how many times do you give
somebody a second chance you know he
said well he said look
if somebody's drowning out there i'll
throw him a rope and i said what if they
don't take it he said i'll throw him
another i said pete what if they don't
take it he said i'll throw him another
and i thought he's gonna go out forever
and i said okay what about the fourth
time he said i let him drown
there you go and i said really you let
him drown he goes don
they chose to drown it's not my
responsibility that's right
and uh you know that's a hard thing to
for those of us who are compassionate
and love people it's a hard thing to
actually say this person is gonna have
to
you know drown or near drown in order to
figure out their life
and i'm not going to get in the way of
that by continuing trying to rescue them